followers of a fast growing conspiracy
group called q anon could have a
significant influence in the upcoming
election
q anon first surfaced back in 2017 now
it maintains that president trump
is leading a war against liberal elites
who according to q anon
are running a global sex trafficking
network including some very famous
people now there is
zero evidence zero that any of this is
true
tonight's episode of sixty and six takes
an inside look at q and on
sixty and six features 60 minute style
storytelling in episodes that last
around six minutes or so
it airs on the streaming app quivi is
produced by cbs news which is part of a
viacom
cbs an investor in quibby 1660
correspondent and founder of dot dot dot
media dot dot dot media that's lori
siegel
spoke with leaders of the movement
dustin nemo's is a part of the q anon
community
and it's also how he makes a living this
is dustin nemos of the nemo's news
network
nemo's posts on his youtube channel
several times a week sometimes
several times a day should we talk a
little bit about covet
and considers himself a seeker of truth
in a
fake news world covet is the biggest lie
fake news has ever told
how can you say that when you look at
the numbers well um i don't trust the
numbers
first of all in new york they supposedly
had hashtag warzone hospitals i had
friends and audience members going out
there with their cell phones saying it's
a ghost town no one's here
you're talking to someone who is in new
york you're talking to a crew of folks
who uh who experienced a lot of this
first hand well why were the hospitals
empty when when these people went there
you saw it on youtube we saw it in in
real life
uh we well we saw it from you we have
heard your version no offense we don't
trust you guys
as someone who was in new york city in
the height of kovis who had
friends in the hospital i can tell you
it just simply isn't true
we had whistleblower nurses who went
into this and exposed what was happening
hospitals were actually monetized and
incentivized
to lie about coveted patients what
evidence do do you have
besides online speculation there's
there's uh months now of documented
evidence for this what kind
uh various articles uh the gateway
pundit zero head just put out many what
kind of article the most news network if
you want to go search
absolutely i've been covering this since
the beginning so i've covered every bit
of it
you know uh more than 200 000 americans
have died since the pandemic i know cbs
has been reporting on these deaths and
has knowledge firsthand
so obviously a pretty intense exchange
there you see we're almost living two
different versions of the truth gail
yeah i'm curious about how you kept your
face on straight lori but i am wondering
how did they gain so many followers
based on all of these false theories
yeah i mean i think that this movement
is growing so quickly and you have this
mysterious figure q who drops these
predictions online
and people are really really following
this and you know i think it's actually
a perfect storm
you have the disenfranchisement of
people you have this pandemic where
people are turning online
and then you also have this growing
distrust of mainstream media you have
the coining of fake news
you have misinformation spreading online
and it really has created a perfect
storm that's led to cue
that's it's very frightening what are
some of the main misconceptions
you know i i think this is something we
can't ignore i've covered
internet movements my whole career for
the last decade and this is
unlike anything i've ever covered these
aren't just people who are
in the their mom's basement right this
is p this is a movement people
really find appealing you know you have
nearly a hundred state and congressional
candidates that are circulating the
messages of q
29 have won primaries being on the
ground you begin to really
understand that people are you know
looking for some type of leadership
looking for something different they're
almost forming their own political party
online so i really don't think we can
ignore this and i don't think we can
ignore how quickly this
is spreading and when they circulate the
messages that you speak of what are the
political implications of that
i i mean extraordinary uh implications
when you're on the ground
one of the interesting things gail is
when when we were in this rally and it
was a pretty intense environment with
the media you know they're filming you
as you're filming them because they
distrust the media but i think the big
question is what's going to happen
when we head towards the election and
will they accept the results you know i
actually spoke to a lot of folks
inside the rally listen to what they
said
president trump's going to get reelected
what if he's not re-elected well he's
going to be reelected what if he's not
real
if president trump is not re-elected
then that's for the american people to
decide if the elections were fair
i think there's going to be a lot of
very angry americans that he wasn't
reelected
it won't happen the only way it'll
happen is with your vote fraud not your
their vote for others so what happens if
he doesn't
then the military will probably step in
the question is will this online
movement move offline
and i think that's what a lot of us are
wondering and a lot of experts who are
looking at this
are wondering and will they accept
results regardless and
and i think that's what i really heard
on the ground because the one of the
things
to note about q anon is donald trump is
really that guiding force they look for
cues
and signs and anything trump tweets and
anything he says gail
and who is cue lori are you able to
figure out who is it male female group
who is this person or group right i had
i had this question i was like you know
everyone is talking about
q and going on and on about you know
these predictions
that haven't come true and what's
interesting is no one knows who q
is uh q is uh and when you go into these
groups a lot of these folks they don't
want to know who q
is and they're not interested in that
and so
q is this mysterious figure who's
posting it could be one person it could
be many people
who's posting these predictions and so
it's almost you know
i put it like this it's almost the
gamification of conspiracy theories
where it's like these people believe in
doing their own research and looking up
their own stuff
and down the rabbit hole the internet
they can find truth in anything and they
don't know who q is
nor do they care all right lori thank
you very much
you can watch lori's full story today on
60 and 6 on the mobile streaming app
quibby